[Music]
hello everybody thanks a lot for coming
to our talk
so I'm Gila Falls and the developer
advocate for Google cloud platform and
I'm Brad Abrams I'm a product manager on
the Google assistant team and we're
going to talk a little bit about how to
extend the assistance with actions on
Google so when sundar announced the
assistant at I alast year it was for one
purpose and that was to build a
conversational interface to Google so
when we think about so we want that
conversational interface to be available
everywhere that that users are so we
want that conversational interface to be
there in your messaging application so
when you're talking to your friends
about where to go out to eat the Google
assistant is there to help you pick a
restaurant we want it to be available in
your pocket when you're trying to figure
out how to get there full access to
everything you can do on your phone and
of course we want the Google assistant
to be there in your home when you're
kicking back listening to some jazz or
if you need to read a recipe or set a
timer we want the assistant to be there
too and of course this is just the
beginning we actually want the assistant
to be available in all kinds of devices
whether that's dishwashers or tractors
so how do we think about the assistant
the way we think about it is that it's a
conversational interface and it's a
conversational interface between you and
Google that helps you get things done in
your world and so the thing I'm really
excited about with the assistant is it
builds on decade or so of research and
development that Google has done in a
wide range of computer science topics
certainly in search not but also natural
language understanding and tint
processing speech recognition
text-to-speech of these core advances
that Google has made but what's really
interesting is the
we brought it together in a really
magical experience but that's not all
what's important to me as a developer is
that we've also built on Google's
history of platforms if you think about
it
Google search was our first platform it
was a platform that connected publishers
with readers then we have a platform
with YouTube today that connects
creatives with their viewers and a
platform with play that connects
application developers with their users
and so building on that rich history of
platforms with Google we have actions on
Google and actions on Google is the way
you as developers can extend the Google
assistance it allows you to connect with
your users wherever the Google assistant
is and it allows you to help users get
things done with whatever service that
you can offer and it allows you to
innovate really in a brand new space a
new paradigm with the way that users are
interacting with computers this gives
you a nice framework a way to experiment
and innovate and so we launched the
platform late last year and we couldn't
be more happy with the actions that
we've seen developed for it
there's hundreds of actions out there
doing all kinds of really interesting
things and I hope that by the end of
this talk you'll be ready to build your
own action for the Google assistants so
let's talk about that action so
Guillaume and I were working on this
knowing this conference was coming up we
thought it'd be great to help users find
their way around the conference so we
build an action that helps users
understand what what sessions are going
on in the conference and how to get
things done and so this is this is just
our demo application and so the way it
works with the assistant on Google home
is that's where we've launched actions
on Google so FAR's on Google home is
users give some sort of query like ok
Google let me talk to cloud next 17 and
then the assistant will respond sure
here's here's cloud
next and then you hear an ear con ear
countenance to the ear when an icon is
to the eye
that's a signification a demarcation
that something is changing in this
dialogue and then our action actually
kicks in and takes over the conversation
and has a two-way dialogue with the user
and that happens in a different voice to
further differentiate the experience
from what's going on with the user so
there are four voices to choose from and
you can go and hear audio clips two male
and two female voices so you can pick
the one that that best matches what
you're trying to accomplish anyway then
there's a two-way dialogue and then when
either party is ready to end that
conversation the conversation goes back
to the assistant after the exit earcon
is played okay so that's the high-level
framework what we're going to do in this
talk is we're going to build that action
for you we're going to walk through the
entire process from the beginning we're
going to talk about designing for this
new mode modality for this eyes-free
modality it's very different experience
than if you built a website or an
application before then we're going to
talk about the development of such an
application both in terms of the machine
learning natural language understanding
aspect as well as connecting to your
back-end systems and hosting of your
business logic then we're going to talk
about how to deploy deploy that action
both in terms of the server deployments
that need to happen as well as how you
help Google understand about that action
with actions on Google ok so I'm going
to jump in and talk about the design
section so first we need to have a
conversation about conversations will we
ever be able taught to talk to machines
the way we talk to people you know
science fiction certainly says that we
can but let's be honest talking to
computers is really difficult today if
you've ever been through one of the
voice trees before you know that
conversing to computers today really
sucks
but that's only because human to human
communication is only deceptively easy
it's nothing short of miraculous that
two people can enter a conversation and
leave it knowing something neither of
them knew going in so it seeks Oh
conversations are easy right well they
are easy for the user in fact they're
probably the easiest way that users have
to interact you don't have to guess what
will happen when I push a button I just
use my natural language but for for us
as developers and software professionals
it's hard these rules are hard to codify
it it's difficult to make a computer
really understand what a user is saying
but it's only it's only easy for us as
humans because we've been doing it our
whole lives conversations are governed
by language and language has rules and
language has syntax and context and as
humans we've gotten amazingly good at
understanding and dealing with context
but take heart
we whoops we don't have to get there
whoops we don't have to get there
overnight humans have been speaking in
language for hundreds of thousands of
years and we've only just started to
have computers try it trying to talk to
humans but this does mean because humans
have been speaking this way so long it's
probably better to teach computers to
talk like humans rather than the other
way around so let's talk more concretely
how do we get computer how do we design
an interface that helped humans talk to
computers well I'm going to offer a
couple of tips for you
the first one is really to create a
persona the way you interact with your
wife or husband is very different than
the way you interact with your boss
that's different the way you interact
with a person
selling tickets because there's a
different persona different roles
involved there so it's no wonder that
the first thing you need to do when you
build your action for the Google
assistant is to think about what persona
you're trying to create so these this is
some rules that we've a process that
we've laid down and we've used it with
many partners it seems to work first we
try to identify our core brand
attributes what is fundamental about our
company or bot that we're trying to
trying to do and so when gingham and I
started working on this action we
thought you know we wanted it to be
knowledgeable helpful encouraging this
kind of experience we wanted out of it
and then we were next to try to tease
out what are those design principles
what are the guide rails that puts on
our development one of the partners we
work with told me this process really
helped them trim features from their
experience by by deciding what the
design principles are so for us we
really wanted to be data rich we wanted
it to consistently recommend and be
proactive and so actually I am spent a
bunch of time getting all the data we
could about what sessions were available
when they were available who was
speaking what room so that we would be a
very data rich experience next think
about the actual dialogue writing what
is the voice what's the style and
persona that we want and for us we
thought maybe a little geeky I mean this
is still a Google conference but eager
and motivating as well and finally we
recommend you create a style guide or
bio sketch that you can use to inform
the writing of dialogue a concrete
artifact and so here's a template of one
this is the one that we used and notice
it says cut sample things that your
action might say what might your action
say what are things that you would just
never say I mean they're they're outside
of their persona you shouldn't say that
and then what words should you use you
know what are some substitute words what
you finally
especially if you're doing this at scale
is you may have several people writing
dialogues for your action
maybe the person changes over time as
happens in development processes and
having an artifact like this that really
makes concrete who you're trying to be
as your action can really help that
leads us to the next one which is around
writing dialogue so here's an actual
sample dialogue that we started writing
and then you could see the mark-up that
we did as we went through and started
applying some of the design principles
that we have and that just gives you a
sense of how this process can go so and
that is really my second tip is really
to go and invest the time to write some
sample dialogue and that can be as
simple as opening up a Google Docs file
and writing dialogue using the style
guide as a way to help yourself
do that but was this a few samples we
suggest you write so first write down
the happy path what's your dream path
the way people are supposed to go
through your action and make sure that's
good and you thought through what the
interactions without are next think
about that first Hung user experience
somebody who's never used it before what
do you do to help them understand the
interaction so that they know what you
can do you frame the problem for them so
that you they ask questions that you're
more likely to be able to answer next is
the opposite which is think about the
returning user once you've earned them
back how can you trim down the
experience or taper the experience so
that they can get to the functionality
they want quicker the next one is there
are no errors in dialogue there's never
an error there's just clarification of
meaning right when we have a
conversation sometimes we misunderstand
each other and we repeat back we clarify
we ask did you mean we get more
information in context before we take
some major action maybe we confirm it if
it's not a major action maybe we are
confident enough to just do it
so thinking about some repair
air scenarios and finally you need to
think about those personality questions
what we've seen from the Google
assistant generally is especially when
users are first starting to use your
actions they prove it and they ask it
some personality questions hi how are
you thank you good evening do you want
to go on a date can I marry you
those are our questions you got to think
about within your persona what are
appropriate answers so regret I don't
want to marry you yeah you don't think
it we'll talk we'll talk okay so that's
a bit on design let's turn it over and
talk about development right I'm a
developer advocate so I'm also
developing a B or C so I'm happy to
speak about development so what's
happening we are users we're talking to
our Google home device the Google home
device is going to interact with the
Google assistants we speak to the device
right so there's speech turn that's
going to be transferred to the assistant
and we're going to do speech to text
analysis to be able to think and react
to what's being said but with words
which are easier well written words say
which are easier to understand them than
voice we do the natural language
processing to extract things like the
entities all the parameters that make
the conversation as well as the intent
of the user the user wants to learn
about a particular session etc and
there's lots of intelligence in there
the ranking picking up who the the user
actually ease etc and as well as
text-to-speech back when we go back to -
to the user so we ask to speak to our
assistants so sure okay here's Google
next 2017
and in the back it's going to call API
AI which contains the our assistance the
structure or the intents all the
entities hi welcome to club mix 17 and
then the conversation really starts so I
want to hear more about machine learning
so again speech recognition etc going on
speech to text and it's going to invoke
API and so there are some things which
can be done automatically from within
API AI let's say canned responses and
things like that but sometimes you
actually need to fetch some data from
somewhere else and that's where we're
going to use the Google cloud platform
and in particular cloud functions which
as you discovered this morning was
announced as beta and that's within
cloud functions that I'm going to write
the business logic of my action and
what's nice is that on the next website
there's actually a REST API that I that
I can invoke to get the list of speakers
the list of sessions the list of topics
etc so my function is going to invoke
that REST API to find the all the talks
with the label machine learning
basically and then okay the next version
running session is blah blah blah and
then with text-to-speech I get the the
response the the session I was
interested in and I let Brad oh yeah no
uh let me just say a few words about
that one and I'll let you two do the
demo afterwards so ATI what is it so
it's cross platform 2 for building
advanced conversational interfaces we
define engine so the difference of
questions or interaction you can have
with your assistance but then those
interactions also need sometimes some
parameters so one intent would be okay I
like to
learn about machine learning likely the
example we had before so the engine is
learning about something but that's
something that's our parameter here so
it's exactly like mapping utterance what
the user says to actually a function
called the function name would be the
intent that we try to call and the
parameters are the parameters like the
topic motion learning that we pass as a
parameter to this engine and I let this
time alright can we have a du by one
okay so what you're seeing is the API de
AI tool and it's a tool that's freely
available everybody can go use it and
it's available right now so it it is the
tool that helps understand this huge
vagaries of human language and turns it
into intents with arguments so here's
the set of instance I have will talk
about a second and then this is a little
test experience here so for example we
can say talk to cloud next 17 and that's
an example user utterance and then it
gives us this the same result we saw on
the slides but what's more interesting
is it's actually taking that text and it
said that goes with this particular
intent and in this case is the default
welcome intent and you can see in this
default welcome intent there's we've
given several user says expressions we
get in several examples of what a user
might say that should come into this
intent and then in this case we've given
some static text that you should respond
so that looks pretty easy like you could
maybe do that with a if statement but it
also works we do some basic machine
learning so you can add add words like
please and it still gets it or can I get
cloud next 2017 it's not a French
keyboard yes
not even so even if there's some
optionality and it learns
time you can do some training on this
more advanced topic so that's pretty
basic actually an aside here is actually
showing us one of the cloud marketing
guys and the prompt is what would you
like to know and I said well clearly the
thing I want to know is where can I get
a cocktail okay market guy on it there's
nobody from cloud marketing here okay
good that's what they wanted to know is
where can I get a cocktail and you can
see we give an OK response here it's
basically the default help intent that
basically we didn't know what the what
to match the two so we matched it to the
health intent so that's kind of not a
great answer so let's actually see what
it would be you know since the marketing
guys are paying for this if we can help
them find their cocktail so let's call
the intent fine cocktail and then what a
user might say if they were looking for
a cocktail
well they might say where are the
cocktails can I get a drink where's the
booze yeah exactly
are there any cocktails so we recommend
between five and Kennedy's expressions
to get started to have enough to have it
makes sense then worked with marketing
to get some approved language for this
action because this is this is the most
important one clearly and now when I
give that same query where can I get a
cocktail notice this time it max to
define cocktails right and in fact is
there a cocktail please still matches so
it's same kind of optionality whatever
gets gets done and if you do some more
training it can get even better so
that's pretty simple let's look at
something a little bit more complex in
this find topics so the way this one
works is we've given several samples but
we've highlighted some things as
entities or slots we're saying anytime
they say breakout sessions whether they
say big data or
another topic then it should match this
intent or are there any talks or I want
to know about or whatnot you can see
this actually matches to a topic so and
the topic is actually an entity so we
flip over to this entity you can see
that we've actually pulled in a lot of
data about what are all the entities
what are all the things that users might
say so for example I believe we are now
in the Big Data machine learning topic
and so we've said look other ways people
might refer to that topic are these are
these aliases so now for example if we
say I need to learn about Big Data then
it will match that hopefully it'll match
that to the fine topic intent that's
great and it actually matched it the
topic to big data and machine learning
so that's pretty cool right it actually
matched it and extracts that entity to
make things more interesting
there's commented in the UX section
about context so if I reset the context
and I say talk to GCP next and I say
more here it says sorry I don't know
what you're talking about because more
doesn't make sense for that prompt but
if I ask about Big Data
then in math hopefully it matches to
that intent and it does then I then here
I can say I want to know more about that
and now more actually has a meaning
we're within a context so the way I'm
sure this is going to work in just a
second yes yes can we just roll over
time yeah there it is the way it works
this time and knew what it was and it
got the data and notice the context is
fine buy more next and that's because we
actually set up that this context when
it leaves this intent it will set that
context and then the more next intent
actually request is guarded by it
requires this find I find my context
next okay so that's the basics there one
more time here's big data and let's see
what the Jason actually looks like so
you can see this is actually what API
they I is going to send to your web hook
so all API they I does is take the
natural language and turn it into a
function with a method call the function
is this it says the action is find by
topic and the parameter here is big data
and machine learning so it's taking this
enormous variety of human language and
turned it into this big data machine
learning fine by topic so now GM is
going to take over and show you how to
process that jason exactly so let's go
back to the slide I'm going to take a
few words about claude function so here
find by topics it's actually going to
call claude functions the cocktails it
was already inside api i didn't have to
get outside of api i but here we're
going to use odd functions for you know
doing the function call let's say the
thing is here I'm speaking about cross
functions but what you need is just
somewhere to have an application
deployed that's able to parse and
produce JSON content basically so it
doesn't have to be on Google cloud
platform it doesn't have to be class
function so you can use anything
anywhere as long as it's a URL which is
available on the on the internet but
white-clad function so it's been a bit
uh announced as because this morning
it's our new server list platform it's
even base or even torii nted there are
three kind of events which are supported
right now cloud storage update so for
example imagine you have
an image which is uploaded and then you
want to react to do them nails and
resizing or applying some filters if
you're using cloud pub/sub it's going to
react to a new message which appears on
some topic but the one we're interested
in it's the HTTP trigger so you can
trigger a cloud function via a call and
HTTP call in our case that's a post
request to our platform so what's
interesting with that card function
[Music]
especially when you're writing something
like like an assistant you are not
necessarily a super wizard with tons of
knowledge of how to deal with with your
you know servers and things like that
that's what's nice with a server let's
approach and with god functions being a
fully managed service you really don't
have to care and worry a worry about the
ops side of things also the other nice
aspect of it is that there's automatic
scaling happening so even if your
assistant is very you know successful
you won't have a problem with scaling
because the scaling is done
automatically it's a fully managed
service and it's also cost effective
because it's not like long-running VMs
or containers it's built by basically
the function core I don't remember the
billing details for cloud functions that
it's pretty cost effective if you don't
get anyone using your agent it won't
cost you anything
and the last aspect which is important
as well is that class functions when you
offer pod functions you devote cloud
functions each using javascript and no
GS so you know pretty much any developer
these days know enough of JavaScript to
be able to write cloud functions so even
if you're you know a front-end developer
you're obviously using JavaScript at
some point so you don't have to be a
back-end developers but if you're a
back-end developer using no GS well fine
and also as that would be also the
announcement of the GA of App Engine
flex by the way and there's no GS
support in App Engine sector you could
also use that alright uh so let's get
back to our little architecture diagram
so we have the user asking the home
device contacting the assistant then
calling API AI then for some of the
interns it's calling our cloud function
which called the REST API exposed on the
next website but yeah before saying that
cloud function is really pretty nifty
when you deploy a new version of
function you know you're giving
okay let's answer somewhat differently
or let's see there's a special case in
the dialog that I need to handle like an
error because be like the next REST API
is not available etc so you you're
developing and then you're you have to
redeploy your function deploying a
function is pretty fast it takes 20 or
30 seconds but when you are developing
you'd like to have somewhat of a tighter
feedback loop and be able to develop
more quickly without having to you know
wait let's say search seconds every five
minutes so you could for five minutes
then you wait to get 30 seconds while
you deploy your changes so it can be a
little bit irritating so I'm going to
tell you about two interesting tools
which allow you to be more productive
and see your changes live so the two
tools I'm going to talk about are and
Rock and the odd functions emulator the
client friction emulator is a way to
actually rent clyde tensions locally on
your machine on localhost basically so
it's a node module it's open source it's
available on github you can use pretty
much the same comments as when you use
g-cloud functions deploy etc it's pretty
much the same set of functions which are
available of commands which are
available
but there are two nice aspects live
reloading so as soon as you make changes
to your code
the changes are taken into account so
you don't have to redeploy anything the
changes are live right away and the
other thing but that I will not cover in
my demo it's the fact that you can also
debug in Chrome what you are doing your
your your code the code of the body of
your function which can be pretty handy
because you know it's not like putting
println statements when you interact or
the println statements is like talking
through the google home device basically
and the other tool so the emulator is
working locally on your machine so it's
as I said on localhost but API I when
you say okay use my web hook pointing at
my cloud function it needs a URL which
is accessible from the web well
localhost is usually not accessible from
the web otherwise you know your machine
might have been you know hacked or
something but there's this nifty little
tool called an grok which is both our
service and come online tool which
creates a tunnel a secure channel over
the Internet to your machine so let's
see that in action please let's move to
the second laptop alright so in our will
we'll have a look at the fine by topic
intent or perhaps the simpler no let's
look at this one fine by topic so we
have over all the possible occurrences
and at the very bottom there's there are
two things which are interesting
advanced I could also mention that what
the action that's how we will refer to
this current instance in our code later
on but the two things I want to show you
is so these are the parameters I want to
find talks about a particular topic so
that's my parameter here
and here I'm using a web hook so this is
how I tell I PII to ping somewhere else
to fetch the data and in the fulfillment
section here this is where you can
define the URL where the calls will be
made so usually normally when I use
cloud function so here I have a few
functions my function here which is the
one I'm using there's a trigger tab
where I can find the URL so usually
that's the one I would have had here but
here I'm using n rock and end rock and
I'm going to do that live let's let's
see that in the channel I'm gonna okay
so when I develop my my function and I'm
going to show you the the kareena in a
moment I have the the emulator available
here so I've already started the
emulator but usually you start the
emulator with doing function start and
then functions deploy agent to well it's
already deployed but I'm doing it again
just for the sake of this demo function
is deploy agent 2 and the I'm using the
HTTP trigger and this is how I function
I deploy sorry the first time my
function so it's available and look at
the accessible URL of course it's on
local host on port 80 10 that's going to
be important because we are going to use
that information for running n drop and
this is the local related path related
to the the domain and here I'm going to
launch and Rock say okay it's in a HTTP
call on port 80 am the end Rock service
is giving me the web accessible URL here
and this is the one I'm gonna copy and
paste in my fulfillment webhook and I
save that
okay and n work is running in here but
there's also if you look at this there's
a web interface and while I'm going to
clear that there's a web interface which
allows you to see all the calls that
came in so you can inspect the request
the response so when I go back here and
I do so I want to hear about App Engine
talks for example it's going to call
here you can see from the command line
that there was a call that was made and
from the interface you can also see the
request here and the restaurant that my
function replied and then let me show
you the code all right so this is
JavaScript not GS I'm using two node
modules there's the this one node fetch
is because I want to interact with a web
api the the one on the next conference
website and this one is more interesting
this is the actions on Google node
module so although you can just consume
and produce JSON there's they are
several cloud SDKs actions SDKs which
are available for different languages
different platforms so here I'm using
the the node.js version I designed some
constants for my different intents and
I'm going to go directly to the end and
here I'm exporting the function here
that's agent to that's the second
version of my function which takes the
request and a response so I'm
initializing the API assistant API I
assistance module then I'm doing the
mapping between the actions that use so
here the actions which were named so
find by topic
you remember me saying something about
action here fine by topic this is the
constant so this is this one fine by
topic and it maps to local function
JavaScript functions that I have so for
example the one I'm interested in that
this one fine by topic so I can get the
argument because my function by my
intent here takes the topic as argument
then I'm doing some string magic to to
make it work well because like when you
have what was the problem I remember
having something with Android and the
let say be the real end connector which
was a little bit weird so what I'm doing
so if there's no topic that was passed
okay sorry I'm going to reply sorry I
don't about that topic could you tell me
more about that
otherwise it's fine I can fetch the
content of the rest API here so I'm
calling the sessions endpoint and then
with that I'm parsing the JSON and then
I'm looking through all the existing
sessions to see which sessions actually
correspond to the topic I'm interested
in so if there is no session found on
that topic sorry I couldn't find any
such session is there another topic
you're interested in and otherwise what
I'm going to do I'm going to set the
context look at this so this is the
context that Brad explained earlier we
found some session so we're going to
look at the first one but I'm going to
add inside the context the the IDS of
all the sessions on that topic because I
want to be able to iterate over the
various sessions which are available so
that I'm able to fetch one after another
and then okay the next session about the
topic is called blah blah blah would you
like to hear more or do you want to move
to the next session so either you kill
more you want the detail the room it
or you want to hear more and so let's
see that in action so you already so the
first goal but when I do so let's say
tell me more that Chrome again so here
this is the the full thing the time the
room number the building and then the
abstract with the details right did you
notice something bread you know yes
thank you I noticed at that time you
know I'm gonna clear in America now like
we don't do this way for our clock okay
okay so I'm French and I usually write
the time 13:20 or it was actually the
military builder yeah yeah yeah alright
alright let me see what I can do for you
Americanize it work yes so this was this
is the fine by topic more intent that's
the one which gives more detail but as
you can see the time I just blindly took
the start are callin stop minute and I
just you know appended the two so I can
be a little bit more clever clever so
I'm gonna comment this one and use this
one instead so if this cut our so I'm
done doing a modulo 12 stop minute and
then if the the the actual hour was
before twelve that's a.m. after twelve
twelve included that's p.m. alright so I
did my chain I'm saving the the changes
I did the changes live okay and when I
go back here and I call more again it's
going to write 120 p.m. I didn't laugh
didn't have to redeploy again or I don't
know recompile or whatever redeploy and
lose like the 30 seconds that I was
mentioning before
all right and then yeah so something I
wanted to mention as well is the the you
can also tale oh I forgot to launch it
you can tell the logs locally locally so
you can see the logs as this as the the
requests coming but when it's deployed
live that's this icon when it's deployed
live I can also see in cloud functions
of course you can also see the logs
thanks to stackdriver
logging alright let's move back to the
slides please
so you had the various modules that you
needed local JavaScript functions and
then you export the actual function use
the assistance tool kit or SDK and there
are many more available in different
wages javascript go Ruby Python and I
don't remember the other ones so that's
basically the structure so it's pretty
you know straightforward kind of
JavaScript so you should be a really
Addison it should be fairly easy to
develop assistance using cloud functions
all right yeah something we can also
show it ultimately you want to use the
real device obviously but we also have a
web simulator for actions on Google so
the we I'm going to show that let's go
back to the second demo laptop so oh
yeah I have to so let me close that so
you you'll come back to that as well in
the integration parts when about the
deployment but you can integrate your
assistance with different things like
facebook Messenger etc but there's also
an integration with the assistant and
Google home so here I'm gonna you're
gonna go into details and see that so
I'm just going to launch the simulator
here so authentication and then there's
a preview button and when I use the
preview button it's gonna let me launch
the simulator again I need to click
start there's one more sonication going
on and then I can do talk to cloud next
seventeen sorry this action is not
available in simulation now sometimes I
think can take some some settings you
talk it go Tok oh yeah sorry
talk to cloud next seventeen sure here's
cloud next seventeen then we can do my
I'll be your guide to Google cloud neck
coming up March 8th through the 10th in
San Francisco I can help you explore
topics or pick a session to attend what
would you like to know and then the
usual flow as we so can continue better
you'll do the real them on the real
device later on yeah back to the slide
earlier on something I wanted to mention
before going back to the slides that you
might notice that the request and
response the the J'son is not exactly
the same as api i that's the one from
the assistance and then the format's are
not necessarily the same but it's also
interesting to debug and see what what's
going on as well all right back to the
slide so I guess it's time to deploy so
when you deploy locally its regis
function deploy agents and then the
trigger HTTP flag and when you deploy on
the real cloud function you do g-cloud
betas functions deploy agent trigger
HTTP that's pretty much the same thing
with the G cloud SDK the sole thing
that's different is the stage buckets
because you'll need a cloud storage
bucket to actually well deploy your code
so that it's being actually deployed in
the in class functions but it's fairly
easy and also
something since we're using nodejs you
can I mean the this line might be might
seem a bit long to write but you can
also in your package JSON JSON file you
can also have some shortcuts so that you
do node ran NPM not NPM run deploy and
then it does open that all the magic
behind the scenes so yeah we deployed
the cloud functions and then good I'll
get that
okay so that was the server deployment
that does bring it back to actions on
Google how do you deploy it so that it's
available on everybody's Google home
wherever the assistant is so there's a
web-based portal where you go and put in
basic triggering information and it's
just part of the same cloud console
developer console that you've been using
and you list basic merchandising
information icon description sampling
vacations and then there's an approval
process there's a set of both automatic
and manual checks that get run so right
now for your very first iteration we're
looking about a one week turnaround just
so you can you can plan on that for some
of the manual checks that get done but
then subsequently it's much quicker than
that for updates to go log and now to
speak a little bit about discovery
within the assistant how do people find
out about your action well one is the
Google home app the directory listing is
there so you can see users can browse
through and find things and then there's
also both guaranteed invocations and
discovery pattern so we think of
guaranteed invocation is much like your
URL you have a URL to your website it's
guaranteed people type in the URL go to
your website so that's true the
guaranteed invitations there's the set
of phrases for example talk to and then
your invitation name will guarantee
users get to you and then there's a
discovery patterns and that's other
triggers that you can register for and
other people can register for them too
and so then there's a ranking problem
which Google's
good at figuring out about who is going
to win that query for that user at that
time based on a whole host of signals so
you can register for those and they can
be reasonably broad and will still let
you have those and occasionally trigger
for them okay let's take a look at a
demo so back to demo one so here we are
in the API manager part of the Google
Cloud console we've just search for the
Google actions API you get here
you give it a what we call a display
name that's what shows up in the
directory but then notice you also have
to give an invocation name so here we're
calling it Google cloud next and notice
I spelled out 20 2017 because there's a
variety of ways you might want your name
read is it 2017 2017 like there's a lot
of different ways to say that and so by
you spelling it out like that way it
makes it clear to us how you want it
said and then based other basic
information then what you do is you go
back to API AI and into integrations and
as Ghia mentioned we have a whole host
of integrations but the best one is
actions on Google of course this and
then now a game showed you the preview
button I'll show you the deployed but
just a highlight
here's that project ID so that's the
connection between what you put in the
console all that merchandising
information with this project and you'll
just click deploy here and we'll just
confirm that and I believe I have one
under review so that won't work but then
you can go it'll it'll submit it for
review and you can see I've done this a
few times and even I occasionally don't
get it past the review but you do get
some detailed explanation as to kind of
why it didn't pass the review and I put
another one in for review so they're
there looking at it right now but this
gives you a sense for where your action
is so we now have our action deployed so
let's take a look
and actually try it on the real go home
which is very risky to do in a large
audience with these speakers and whatnot
so we're going to do the best we can and
then we have a video and perhaps we
could also could you switch to the demo
machine the second one because I can
also since I let the local development
instead of putting the right engine
right deployment functions you'll see
the the actual requests coming in okay
let's just try a basic thing that
actually this is the most common query
done hey Google what time is it
the time is 611 p.m. right so that it's
an expensive clock hey Google talk to
cloud next 17 sure here's cloud next 17
hi I'll be your guide to Google cloud
next coming up March 8th through the
10th in San Francisco I can help you
explore topics or pick a session to
attend what would you like to know I
need to learn about Big Data the next
session about Big Data and machine
learning is called introduction to Big
Data tools that deliver deep insights
would you like to hear more about it or
hear about the next session Metro sure
sure the next session is optimizing the
value of data processing would you like
to hear more about it or about the next
session but sure the next session is
infuse your business with machine
learning would you like to hear more
about it or about the next session or
more about work for you
sure here is more information the
presentation starts at 3:00 10:00 p.m.
in room 2002 at Moscone Center West the
abstract says with machine learning
instead of programming a computer you
teach a computer to learn something and
it does what you direct it to do in this
discussion we'll share an overview of
machine learning and how your business
can benefit from it
we'll cover the spectrum of ways Google
uses machine learning and how businesses
can
leverage the technology that we've
open-sourced the kuruma fuel also learn
how you can embed machine learning in
your applications today and create new
applications powered with machine
learning would you like to hear about
the next session no I'm good thanks
goodbye and have a good time at GCP next
okay so that's our action lies thank you
okay that's right yeah can we switch
back to the slides please okay we don't
have to show the video amazing okay so
that could be hopefully the key
takeaways you have from this is that you
can and should even extend the assistant
with your own custom action I hope you
have like a hundred ideas in your head
right now of things that you could go
build I look forward to seeing you in
the review process hopefully you
understand now that API to a I can make
talking with humans approachable and
something that you can actually go
accomplish and that the cloud platform
here offers a really powerful way to do
your business logic and just some other
resources there's a few other talks that
are in this general domain if you're
more interested in kind of the box I'd
especially box an enterprise space there
was a talk you've already missed that
one but you can watch it on the on the
stream later if you want to know more
about API todayI including other
scenarios outside of the assistant and
how it can be used for say Facebook or
embedded in websites and apps there was
another talk that you also missed on
that and but that's also available
online later we were the last one then
of course ours ours and I saw some
people taking pictures of the UX design
resources we've actually put a good set
of white papers up a whole checklist a
bunch of resources because we really
think this is the key to having really
high quality user experiences wherever
you're building your conversational
interfaces so please take advantage of
that
oh and with that we've got time for a
couple questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]